I've just come from chairing seven hours
of cabinet meetings focused on finding a
route out of the current and pass one
that will deliver the Greg search the
British people voted for I'd allow us to
move on and begin bringing our divided
country back together I know there are
some who are so fed up with delay and
then disarmament that they would like to
leave with no deal next week
I've always been clear that we could
make a success of no deal in the long
term but leaving with a deal is the best
solution so we will need a further
extension of article 51 that is as short
as possible and which ends when we pass
a deal and we need to be clear what such
an extension is for to ensure we leave
in a timely and orderly way this debate
this division cannot drag on much longer
it is putting members of parliament and
everyone else under immense pressure as
it is doing damage to our politics
despite the best efforts of MPs the
process that the House of Commons has
tried to lead has not come up with an
answer so today I am taking action to
break the logjam I'm offering to sit
down with the leader of the opposition
and to try to agree a plan that we would
both stick to to ensure that we leave
the European Union and that we do so
with a deal any plan would have to agree
the current withdrawal agreement it has
already been negotiated with the 27
other members and the EU has repeatedly
said that it cannot and will not be
reopened what we need to focus on is our
future relationship with the EU the
ideal outcome of this process would be
to agree an approach on a future
relationship that delivers on the result
of the referendum that both the leader
of the Opposition and I could put to the
house for approval and which I could
then take to next week's European
Council however if we cannot agree on a
single unified approach
then we would instead agree a number of
options for the future relationship that
we could put to the house in a series of
votes to determine which course to
pursue crucially the government stands
ready to abide by the decision of the
house but to make this process work the
opposition would need to agree to this
too the government would then bring
forward the withdrawal agreement bill we
would want to agree a timetable for this
bill to ensure it is passed before the
22nd of May so that the United Kingdom
need not take part in European
parliamentary elections this is a
difficult time for everyone passions are
running high on all sides of the
argument but we can and must find the
compromises that will deliver what the
British people voted for this is a
decisive moment in the story of these
islands and it requires national unity
to deliver the national interest